[Musique]
au programme aujourd'hui dans ce set 8
sport du football dans le championnat de
r2 où il a raté l'occasion de prendre le
large en tête du championnat des
yvelinois se sont inclinés 1 0 sur leur
terrain face à l'équipe 2 de bobigny le
résumé du match cyclisme une compétition
de bmx était organisée ce samedi au
stadium national de bmx de saint quentin
en yvelines le rendez vous attire et des
sportifs professionnels dont des têtes
d'affiché enfin les championnats
scolaires académique d'échecs se sont
déroulés ce mercredi 23 mars un poignard
pour la première fois plus de 150 jeunes
se sont affrontés sur ce jeu ce sera
notre module découverte
un choc pour cette journée de r2 ou i
premier recevait son dauphin l'équipe 2
de bobigny un match alléchant sur le
papier qui ne tient pas toutes ses
promesses sur le terrain lors de la
première période les deux équipes se
neutralisent 0 à 0 à la pause en
première mi temps on n'était pas
craintif mais on était prudent donc on
n'a pas pu vraiment jouer notre notre
football on n'a pas pu aussi mettre en
place tout ce que le coach a demandé
donc du coup c'était une mi temps mitigé
on sentait qu'on n'était pas vraiment en
danger mais on voulait pas à s'exposer
en seconde période où ils insistent mais
ne parvient pas à marquer un manque de
réussite qui se paye cash les jours de
bobigny marque sur cette action 1 à 0
les yvelinois poussent pour revenir dans
la partie mais ils n'arriveront pas à
égaliser 1 0 ce sera le score final sur
leur seule occasion du match il trouve
le but est la moins été efficace on a
manqué d'envié on avait à coeur de
gagner ou au moins de ne pas de pas de
perdre sur leur seule occasion des
mutants
ils ont réussi à nous faire mal je pense
qu'ils ont réussi à nous faire déjouer
on n'a pas pris le match par le bon bout
donc il ya beaucoup de frustration et
déception dans le vestiaire des joueurs
et du coach aussi bien chaud après cette
défaite où il est toujours leader mais
ne compte plus que deux points d'avancé
à sept matches de la fin du championnat
ça relance tout le monde donc notamment
embaument unique sans d'arnaud donc ils
vont rien lâcher c'est à dire que faudra
quand même être vigilant par rapport à
eux mais encore une fois comme j'ai dis
qu'est-ce qu'on a le destin en main un
ou deux justement mettre toutes les
chances de notre côté pour justement
arrivé à la fin de l'année et a toujours
premier pour continuer à croire en la
montée où il se déplacera ce dimanche 3
avril sur le train de vallière crown
quatrième du classement
[Musique]
football toujours une légende du
championnat américain décidé de prendre
sa retraite après onze saisons passées
en mls les viennois aurélien collin
décidé d'arrêter à l'âge de 36 ans le
défenseur central a fait cette annonce
la semaine dernière pendant sa carrière
le joueur qui portait le numéro 78 a
notamment joué chez le sporting de
kansas city entre 2011 et 2014 il a
gagné avec ce club une coupe en major
league soccer le footballeur est ensuite
passé par orlando new york encore
philadelphie il totalise 196 apparition
dans le championnat américain
au début de ce tour des résultats du
week-end par du football dans la
première division départementale des
yvelines quatre clubs se disputent la
montée en régionale 3 premiers du
classement le voisin football club s'est
imposé à la maison contre le fc vallée
78,4 buzyn victoire également de son
dauphin le s sartrouville 5 3 face à
gargenville même score pour le chesnay
en réception de l'ès carrière grésillons
seule équipe réserve de où il perd des
points sur la course en tête après son
nul 1-1 face à bailly noisy enfin situe
en milieu de tableau et poney buchelay
ont su se défaire de l'ess bois d'arcy
et de la lanterne rouge aubergenville
rien ne va plus pour l encours en
deuxième division de football américain
une défaite la troisième de suite pour
les templiers c'était cette fois ci face
à bordeaux le score 6 à 14
toujours deuxièmes du classement ils
auront l'occasion de se ressaisir dès ce
week-end sur le terrain et corsair
d'evry la piste ok c'était ce dimanche
27 mars plus de 700 personnes ont pris
le départ des deux courses de 5 et 10 km
au 5 km et djawad abdos moula de l'ice
poissy triathlon l'a emporté en 15
minutes 02 secondes et vainqueur des 10
km la course reine de l'événement
raphaël aurélien avec son dossard 844
plus d'une minute avant tous les autres
en trente et une minutes et 42 secondes
un mot du grand prix de montigny comme
tous les événements du week-end la
course cycliste s'est déroulé sous un
grand soleil au programme de départ 1 de
54 km un autre de 75 parmi les 18
cyclistes du vcmb le club de montigny le
bretonneux une récompense et fanny
jacques première féminine de la course
de 54 km au total environ 180 coureurs
ont pris le départ des deux courses en
tennis pas d'exploit pour arthur
rinderknecht au masters 1000 de miami
après avoir battu le serbe lazlo dirait
l'yvelinois 58e mondiale n'a pas su
trouver la solution face au 10e mondial
ou bear ou catch au deuxième tour de la
compétition
une défaite 7 6 6 2 enfin la rugbywoman
yvelinoise emilie boulard est une
nouvelle fois marqué de son empreinte le
match du quinze de france féminin pour
l'entrée en matière des françaises au
tournoi des six nations elle inscrit le
quatrième essai synonyme de bonus
offensif face à l'italie un rush de 40
mètres en esquivant deux plaquages pour
aplatir près de l'en but les bleus se
sont imposés 39 à 6
du soleil des pilotes amateurs et
professionnels et des centaines de
spectateurs le premier rendez vous des
bmx pro series au stadium national de
saint quentin en yvelines a tenu toutes
ses promesses samedi 26 mars l'événement
regroupait plus de 300 pilotes tout au
long de la journée sur un format digne
des jeux olympiques c'est une
confrontation 108 sur une butte de
départ et c'est le premier qui arrive au
bout des 4 100 m
logiquement avec la fédération il ya une
classification qui elle est qui et qui
en partie prises avec les quatre
premiers et ça découle sur les seizièmes
des huitièmes des cartes comme dans
n'importe quelle discipline parmi les
pilotes des étrangers venus découvrir la
piste et s'imprégner de l'ambiance en
vue des jeux olympiques de 2024 à paris
ils sont venus des quatre coins du monde
c'est vraiment cool d'été ici la paix
c'est franchement vraiment rapide c'est
un belle piste je pense que c était
vraiment cool de rouler avec tous les
pans son essai avec les publics et tout
ça ça a été franchement vraiment cool
sur ce stadium de bmx de 50 ans ni ville
on retrouvait également des membres de
l'équipe de france présent sur les
grands rendez vous mondiaux on connaît
bien la piste ici vu que c'est le centre
d'entraînement de l'équipe de france de
bmx donc on connaît bien la piste c'est
toujours agréable de venir ici ils ont
bien préparé la piste ils ont bien
nettoyer tout ça donc c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment super elle est
particulièrement
particulièrement propre pour la
compétition et franchement ça roule ça
roule super bien on a des bonnes
conditions
nouveau rendez-vous bmx pro series est
déjà programmé en octobre prochain sur
le même format jusqu'en 2025 le stadium
de 50 ans neeve il devrait accueillir au
minimum deux compétitions chaque année
la nouvelle est tombée la semaine
dernière la ville de versailles
accueillera l'équipe du pays de galles
dans le cadre de sa préparation à la
coupe du monde de rugby 2023 qui sont
organisés en france le quinze du poireau
demi finaliste de la dernière édition en
2019 s'installera dans la cité royale
pendant quatre semaines et demie du 8
septembre au 28 octobre du côté du stade
de porchefontaine
[Musique]
[Rires]
les championnats académiques sont
organisées ici à coignières pour la
première fois nous sommes le mercredi 23
mars la présentation de cet événement
[Musique]
à mes côtés mark bittman l'un des
organisateurs à leur marque qu'est ce
que c'est que cet événement alors ici on
est au championnat scolaire académique
de versailles donc une des trois
académies d'île de france et qui va
désigner le champion des écoles est le
champion des collèges qui pourra ensuite
participé aux championnats de france
scolaires et s'est dessinée à qui s'est
dessinée donc à tous les enfants qui ont
eu un enseignement des échecs sur le
temps scolaire donc les écoles de 6 à 11
ans dès le cp on a plusieurs enfants qui
sont au cp actuellement et les
collégiens de 11 à 15 ans environ et
niveau les comment justement bon il est
déjà une légende très fort alors on a on
a une partie du joueur de club donc ses
classes et fait des équipes de 8 2 les
premiers échiquiers sont souvent des dix
joueurs expérimentés et les derniers
échecs et sondé vraiment des enfants qui
ont découvert les échecs sur le temps
scolaire et qui découvrent la
compétition est ce que les futurs cracks
ici à jeu je l'espère c'est le but aussi
de faire ces événements de découvrir des
nouvelles pépites on en a plusieurs en
france donc peut-être les prochaines
seront parmi nous la commande explique
cet engouement il ya des enfants de 6
ans qui sont derrière nous comment elles
expliquent cet engouement des six ans de
vouloir faire les échecs alors on a
on a le premier prescripteur sont les
parents les papas les mamans qui leur
apprennent à jouer et après c'est
justement ce temps scolaire de plus en
plus d'enseignants de mettre deux
maîtresses font font les échecs sur le
temps scolaire et donc c'est un
substitut aux mathématiques à travailler
la mémoire la réflexion est donc ça ça
plaît beaucoup aux enseignants et donc
ça développe énormément cette discipline
chez les enfants c'est la question qui
revient énormément est ce que les échecs
sont un sport alors les échecs oui ce
sont 1 sport ils sont affiliés au
ministère des sports on est discipline
délégataire du ministère des sports il
ya près de soixante mille licenciés en
france et
je vous garantis que que les meilleurs
joueurs au monde ont un niveau physique
extrêmement développé c'est très
important d'avoir un bon physique jouer
aux échecs pendant des heures demande
une énergie folle et donc il faut être
vraiment au point physiquement il ya des
temps de récupération aussi pour les
plus grands on a les plus grands joueurs
ne font une partie par jour au maximum
pas capables d'en faire plus des vrais
partis officiels et souvent au bout de
deux trois jours ils ont une journée de
récupération donc c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment éprouvant physiquement vous
êtes un ancien joueur est ce que si vous
êtes admirative de voir ces jeunes
derrière
oui parce que comme vous disiez avant
maintenant ça joue beaucoup plus jeune
qu'à mon époque moi j'ai commencé à 9
ans 10 ans j'étais un tout petit
maintenant c'est des quatre ans des
premiers cours sont donnés à 4 ans et
donc voir des enfants de 4-5 ans jouer
est déjà très bien joué c'est assez
incroyable et vous me disiez juste avant
l'interview certains battent déjà leur
papa en fait c'est ça ah oui alors c'est
génial d'avoir des enfants qui
apprennent à jouer aux échecs parce que
ils battent leurs parents leur papa leur
maman et ensuite les papas et mamans
viennent au club parce qu'ils en ont
marre de perdre contre leurs enfants et
donc ils veulent apprendre aussi et donc
ça fait développer toute la famille est
une émulation familiale est-ce que j'ai
le sentiment que les échecs ont pris une
nouvelle ampleur depuis quelques mois
quelques années on sait qu'il ya eu des
séries à succès sur sur des plateformes
de streaming est-ce que ça va permettre
à aux échecs de encore plus se
développer dans les prochaines années
alors le confinement déjà énormément
développé d'activité échiquéenne sur les
plates formes en ligne donc on a les
plateformes ont décuplé en nombre de
d'adhérents et à la fin du confinement
on a noté une explosion et un engouement
extrêmement fort pour les clubs donc oui
ça nous a beaucoup aidés et
effectivement le jeu de la série de jeux
de la dame a amené aussi une population
féminine beaucoup plus importante
puisque les échecs rester une discipline
plutôt masculine avec 17 18 % de
licenciés filles et maintenant on
augmente significativement sa avec grâce
à grâce à cette série on le voit juste
derrière elle a certains qui ont déjà
gagné leur parti oui bah ça c'est pas
forcément une bonne chose c'est qu'ils
ont joué beaucoup trop vite et c'est un
peu l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à ralentir
et à les faire réfléchir plus parce
qu'il joue trop vite quand ils sont
jeunes on va les rencontrer justement
[Musique]
et dans cet événement il ya également à
des yvelinois ils viennent de montfort
l'amaury il y à gaspard et adrien qui
viennent tout juste de terminer leur
partie alors gaspard comment ça s'est
passé bah au début je l'avais la
personne je la battais mais en fait al
adl a déplacé sa dame et du coup j'ai
perdu parce que là il y avait son
cavalier qui l'a protégé du coup j'ai
pas pu la manger avec mauroy et j'avais
pas vu le coup venir et du coup j'ai
perdu voilà est pour toi de rien moi je
les gagner ce match c'était assez serré
mais j'ai réussi en fait il a mis un
comptage hardy donc j'ai gagné deux
minutes mais ensuite je lui ai offert en
cour interdit parce que sinon ils
perdent m haies et façon j'étais en
train de le battre j'ai gagné en un
échec et mat avec une tour est un droit
c'est important ça soit en équipe ou
partager aussi quelque chose
d'intéressant bas en équipe ça permet de
vivre le truc ensemble
rires ou être déçu en même temps ce vous
fêter ce soir là là bas il ya plein de
coupe c'est pour le collège pour ceux
qui gagnent c'est une victoire en équipe
c'est là une équipe qui a gagné c'est
pas un c'est pas une personne qui ait
gagné c'est tout l'été c'est toute la
personne tout le collège est ce que ça
rendez vous important pour vous est ce
que vous y êtes préparé depuis de
longues semaines
passées en jouant sur les sur les jeux
d'échecs en ligne etc by adrien oui
parce que on joue une fois toutes les
deux semaines au club d'échecs de
montfort à l'école le vendredi pour
passer le temps aussi sa a été créée au
début d'année du collège
et aussi je télécharge des applications
pour jouer en ligne contre des gens et
pour m'entraîner justement c'est pour ça
si j'ai bien compris vous êtes vraiment
des mordus à vous d échec ouais c'est ça
on adore vraiment pas moi en tout cas
vous y jouez comme en temps je sais pas
beaucoup mais
pas vraiment je joue pas beaucoup mais
par contre en ligne j'y joue beaucoup
parce que j'aime bien m'entraîner compte
deux joueurs voient leurs stratégies et
trouver des d'être à tes yeux pour les
contrer mais comment vous expliquer
justement cette passion pour les échecs
c'est pas forcément courant chez tous
les jeunes de votre âge qu'on vous
l'expliquer un mois c'est que j'ai
commencé très tôt et quand j'étais très
tôt et quand dès l'âge de 8 ans
un petit peu avant sans que je pense et
j'ai quand j'ai commencé je commençais à
jouer tout seul je regardais les pièces
tournées autour et après j'ai commencé à
jouer contre mon père et je le battais à
8 ans et du coup après j'ai continué et
du coup c'est pour ça que j'adore
vraiment parce que tu m'as tu es ton
père ouais c'est ça même chose pour toi
de rien c'est presque ça parce que moi
cinq ans
mon père il m'a acheté un jeu d'échecs
de va c'était pour mon grand frère mais
il ne joue pas et en fait j'ai lu le
bouquin des règles et je me j'ai bien
aimé le concept et du coup j'ai joué
contre mon père au début il me battait
parce que j'étais jeune je connaissais
pas trop les règles mais ensuite j'ai
appris les ouvertures des stratégies et
j'ai réussi à le constat le battre et du
coup j'étais content et et après j'ai
compris qu'il y avait un atelier d'échec
au collège et je me suis inscrit
directement pour continuer à m'entraîner
à plein temps si j'ai bien compris à
chaque fois c'est pour vous battre vos
pairs c'est bien ça mais c'est pas la
première chose qu'on veut nous nous on
veut s'amuser surtout c'est notre
première chose en plus c'est une
activité qu'on aime c'est bien c'est
stratégique et ça fait mémoriser des
choses et ça peut être mieux pour la
mémoire selon vous comment peut être
fort aux échecs ben il faut beaucoup
d'entraînement il faut d'ailleurs
beaucoup de livres dessus et faut
surtout sans beaucoup d'entraînement
c'est ce qui est le plus important est
bien connaître les règles
je dirais que le but c'est pas de
devenir force et de s'amuser en jouant
et c'est comme ça justement qu on
devient fort et on s'entraînant et en
faisant des défaites parce que c'est là
c'est la voie pour gagner
dernière question vos objectifs à tous
les deux dans ce sport
moi c'est m'amuser c'est surtout
m'amuser c'est une activité et en plus
ça fait réfléchir et du coup j'adore
bah pareil comme ricky jouer pour
m'amuser et non pour gagner même si
j'aime bien gagner perdre peut être
aussi très bien ça peut apprendre des
erreurs et
nous améliorer merci à tous les deux et
bon courage pour la suite de la
compétition
[Musique]
didier fischer j'imagine que vous êtes
ravi d'accueillir à cette compétition
pour la première fois ici à coignières
oui oui effectivement je suis vraiment
ravi d'accueillir cette compétition à
une compétition d'échecs d'échec
scolaire mais au bon sens du terme
effectivement et on sait bien que les
échecs sont une école de rigueur pour
nos pour nos enfants et effectivement
c'est un facteur évident de réussite
scolaire et je suis vraiment ravi
d'accueillir cette compétition
aujourd'hui à coignières vous le disiez
c'est un sport avant tout et qui est de
développement à des enfants oui c'est un
sport qui aide au développement des
enfants qui leur permet de mieux se
concentrer qui leur permet de réfléchir
qui leur permet de développer des
stratégies et ça c'est tout ce dont ils
ont besoin tout au long de leur vie donc
c'est essentiel et c'est vrai qu'on a
décidé ça fait deux ans on a mis en
place cette activité dans les écoles et
au centre de loisirs aussi l'impression
que c'est un sport qui prend de plus en
plus d'ampleur où l'on parle de plus en
plus des échecs oui on en parle de plus
en plus et surtout c'est le milieu
scolaire qui s'en est emparé aujourd'hui
il ya des consignes très précises aussi
des je dirais des autorités de
l'éducation nationale pour qu'on puisse
mettre en place cela dans nos écoles
c'est une grande première ici à cognin
ce qui aura d'autres événements de ce
type à accueillir dans les prochains
mois les prochaines années où il est
bien entendu dans les prochaines années
de toute façon on est ouvert à
accueillir des événements au moins de
cette importance là voire peut-être un
événement de dimension régionale
nationale peut-être parce que vous vous
êtes fan d'échecs je ne suis pas fan
d'échecs parce que j ai jamais joué mais
bon j'apprécie le jeu et je commence à
m'y mettre justement grâce aux enfants
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
150 élèves des matches à huit contre
huit et une dose de bonne humeur ces
championnats ont été une réussite ici à
coignières et la grande finale des
écoles aura lieu au mois de juin ce sera
à brissac
philippines et à tôt le directeur du
golf national de saint-quentin lévy
l'état mais à côté pour présenter cette
nationale golfweek alors qu'est ce que
c'est cette nationale golfweek et à
philippe bas ça va être la fête du golfe
ça va être la fête du golfe pendant
pendant pendant trois jours sur le sur
le site du golf national
donc semaine prochaine donc c'est bien
tome donc salon du golf qui pour je
crois que c'est la première fois en
france que ça se déroule sur un golf et
notamment en tout cas sur eux s'ils
doivent nationale et donc voilà on est
très fiers de pouvoir accueillir cet
événement bah maintenant que printemps
est arrivé sur cette période mais c'est
un événement vraiment ouvert à tous bah
oui oui c'est vraiment le salon du golf
et la fête du boeuf donc ça va être
ouvert aux jeunes aux moins jeunes aux
professionnels aux amateurs il va avoir
des compétitions avec donc des
programmes avec un beau plateau puisque
belle on va dire la crème des golfeurs
français seront là avec alexander levy
avec raphaël jacquelin avec grégory
havret joanna klatten enfin beaucoup de
beaucoup de gros noms qui seront là et
en complément de ça on va avoir oscillé
compétition sur le parcours de l'aigle
ou là sur ce parcours là ce avait des
compétitions destinées à des seniors
destiné à des jeunes est ce qu'on peut
dire que c'est finalement logique de
l'accueillir ici ce salon du golf au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines my way c'est
logique nous on est on est extrêmement
on est très heureux quand tout cas que
la décision a été prise d'organiser ça
sur le sur le civil national parce qu'en
complément de
de l'événement avec les exposants avec
le village qu'on pouvait le voir
derrière qui va quand même accueillir à
peu près un peu plus d'une centaine
d'exposants ce qui est quand même
beaucoup
mais il valeur du jeu donc je pense que
c'est assez sympa 2e
d'avoir à la fois bella visites
institutionnelles les stands préparer
son voyage pour pour cet été voyage
golfique et en complément de sable de
pouvoir avoir un complément et en
contrebas bdl et les meilleurs joueurs
français qui seront là oui on le voit
derrière vous vous disiez un philippe ça
se prépare bien derrière ouais ouais
c'est assez gros un très honnêtement à
je vais être franc avec vous je
m'attendais pas à quelque chose d'aussi
gros donc donc ça c'est une bonne chose
donc versicolor à vue à vue a mis les
petits plats dans les grands et à vue a
fait quelque chose de gros et c'est bien
parce que comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure ils ont quand même réussi à
solliciter une centaine d'exposants en
complément de cela il va y avoir
également des équipementiers qui seront
là donc tous les équipementiers majeurs
seront présents sur le site pour pouvoir
faire des tests faire essayer le
matériel aux personnes qui seront sursis
donc c'est sûr rendez vous est donc oui
oui tout à fait ça va être cesser en
gros c'est un gros événement oui l'idée
c'est de rester vraiment toute la
journée ici au golf national voire même
les trois jours oui oui tout à fait
c'est à dire que l'idée c'est de passer
la journée parce que je pense qu'il y
aura tellement de choses à voir que la
journée va passer assez vite à la fois
en complément du jeu en complément du
village en complément des exposants il
va y aura également des espaces
restauration je pense que très
honnêtement que le temps soit beau comme
on l'a aujourd'hui ça peut être une
journée très agréable s'il est un peu
moins bon c'est pas très gênant parce
que toutes les façons le village est
tellement grand qu'on peut se mettre
voile à l'abri pour échanger et discuter
autour d'une passion commune qu'est le
golf et puis passer une journée sur le
site du golf national je pense qu'il ya
quand même des endroits plus plus
désagréable que cela oui tout à fait et
on peut regarder les matchs aussi de
golf y aura quelques matchs match plein
oui c'est ça il va y avoir des matches
pays ce qu'ils appellent leur seul match
play les jeudi et vendredi vont seront
des équipes que l'on joue en alliant
c'est donc avec un pro impro impro impro
majeur on va dire comme je vous ai donné
tout à l'heure les noms et ensuite trois
amateurs qui vont qui vont jouer donc et
sur le parcours de l'albatros mais ce
qui est quand même assez atypique et de
façon à donner un petit peu plus de on
va dire de piment et d'intérêts au je
sais que les joueurs vont jouer sur les
trous numéro 1 2 15 16 17 18 cars qu'à
la fois le circuit final qu'est vraiment
on va dire le le le on va dire le
l'apothéose sur le dr souvient la rider
avec toutes ces personnes ici autour et
puis les trous numéros 1 et 2 qui sont
aussi deux des trous les plus
intéressants à jouer sur le parcours de
l'albatros donc 1 2 15 16 17 18 donc ça
va faire du monde autour des parties et
sur les parties ou en fait on va voir du
jeu avec un peu peut-être de trois
balles dans l'eau mais c'est sympa ça
vous savez combien de personnes à peu
près par jour ben par jour à la jauge
était aux alentours de 4000 après
derrière 6
6-6 il fait très beau et que que voilà
on peut encore on peut dépasser ces
jauges l'a donc nous on a en mesure 1 en
capacité d'accueillir beaucoup plus de
personnes et c'est ce qu'on espère bien
question comment ça coûte pour venir ici
ben en fait ça coûte pas cher en fait un
saut coûte pas cher saccucci si vous
n'êtes pas licencier ses 15 euros la
journée si vous êtes licencié ses 10
euros et après vous avez vous avez des
paquets tous non licenciés ces 30 pour
les 3 jours et le licencier 25 euros
merci philippe lattaud merci
[Musique]